This is basically a soap opera for apes.
Silly as it seems, researchers made videos
like this
to show that non-human apes can recognize
that others may have false beliefs.
It’s part of research investigating “theory
of mind” which asks questions like:
What do great apes like chimps, bonobos, and
orangutans think about others’ minds?
Humans do this all the time.
We think about what others are thinking:
Their goals, intentions, expectations and
beliefs, even false ones.
But it was thought only people could understand
if someone else had the wrong idea about something.
This experiment was set up to see if other
primates could do this.
The subjects watched a drama play out and
their eye movements are tracked to see what
they expect the players to do.
They sip juice from a fixed straw, which holds
them still enough that their gaze can be tracked.
The dramatic conflict in the soap opera keeps
the primates interested—they need to be
invested enough to closely watch the scene.
Adding an ape-like creature reminiscent of
“King Kong” and some social conflict was
just enough to keep their attention.
Here’s what happens in an ape soap opera,
step-by-step:
First, the human shows interest in a rock.
Note the chimp observer in the upper left-hand
corner of the screen.
It’s eyes are being tracked through this
entire process.
Then, the mysterious primate comes in and
takes the rock, making a lot of noise as it
does so.
The red dots show
that the chimp is watching
the scene intently.
The human AND the chimp both watch
the mystery primate hide the rock under the LEFT box.
Then the human suddenly leaves.
While the human is gone, the chimp watches
the rock being moved
--the red dots show all these motions are being tracked
-- until finally the rock is removed altogether.
The chimp sees the person coming back into
the room and reaching for the boxes.
Where does the chimp think the person is going
to look for the rock?
According to its gaze, the chimp looks on
the left, even though it knows the rock is
gone.
In a series of these trials, all three species
of apes tested (orangutans, chimps, and bonobos)
looked where they thought the human would go
suggesting that these apes recognized a false
belief in another mind.
According to this research, non-human apes
appear to understand that individuals have
unique perceptions about the world.
The person doesn’t know the rock is gone
so the ape looks where they think the person
thinks it is.
This finding suggests that these apes, too,
have some understanding of what’s happening
in another individual’s mind
and threatens to tip “theory of mind”
off the "human only" pedestal.